so far we've seen 18 players on the
covet 19 reserve list according to nfl
media these are the guys that are
testing positive on the way in so far
there's been transparency as to the
players who test positive and yesterday
we were talking about opt-outs lauren
durante tardif of the chiefs was the
first guy to opt out friday night that's
one another seven or eight have opted
out since then we're going to put a full
tracker together at pft marcus cannon
the veteran
patrol that's official lineman
yeah he is opting out this is a guy
who's had cancer he's a guy whose cancer
was discovered at the scouting combine
in 2011 he had a growth for like five
years and it was downplayed by doctors
and a couple of teams finally said you
need to get a biopsy and it turned out
he had non-hodgkin's lymphoma so he's
he's beaten that and uh he's he's in one
of the risk categories so he's one of
the ones who is um opting out and uh
again if you opt out your contract gets
told until next year if you opt out in a
high-risk category you get 350 000 and a
stipend in a non-high risk category you
get 150 000 it's an advance on next
year's salary and if you don't make the
team you got to pay it back
good luck collect good luck collecting
though i was gonna say like you're gonna
look real cool as a team asking for a
guy for you know money back after the
you know kova 19 a bunch of billionaires
asking for guys like that that's not
going to be good
how how dare you after a year off of
football that you conscientiously chose
to take because we told you you could
you couldn't make the team the next year
because you haven't played now in 20
months how dare you fail to make the
roster give us back our 350 thousand
dollars that's going to be a bad look it
is if anybody tries to enforce that yeah
demarcus lawrence the cowboys defensive
lineman has suggested maybe he would opt
out he is going to show up
for
the start of training camp today the
window still isn't closed on opting out
chris i think there's gonna be a
category of guys
who have the attitude of
i'm gonna go and see how i feel right
i'm gonna go and see what it looks like
i'm gonna go and just get that you know
the the equivalent of when you lick the
finger and you put it up in the air and
you see which way the wind's blowing you
just want to get a sense of how
seriously the team is taking it and if
you feel like they're taking it
seriously enough that's a factor in not
opting out if you show up and say well
this is just going to be a train wreck
uh then you say see you later and maybe
you have to give it a few days to get to
that that sense where you have a gut
feeling as to what you should do yeah i
i mean i i would think there's going to
be a number of guys that are kind of
going into training camp with a little
trepidation just i don't know what to
expect is this good is this smart i'm
not sure
okay yeah hey honey i'm going to go and
kind of just get a feel for it and see
if it what's been put in place can make
me feel comfortable and you're right i
would think we see a few guys at least a
handful of guys drop out you know after
they've gone for a few days and they
realize like wow this is some pain in
the butt this is unstoppable i don't
know about this i don't feel comfortable
with the locker room still i know we're
spaced whoever there's going to be guys
that are not going to feel comfortable
the big thing is we've yet to have that
major star
like and if if demarcus lawrence does
that you know i think that's going to
open some eyes and that's that's a game
game-changing move as far as just the
competitive balance of the nfl this
season dallas we know they're good on
paper they're talented they have one
little they you know they have an issue
on their team it's probably pass rusher
and now you're going to lose their best
pass rusher that would be a big blow to
that football team just on the field
alone but might also embolden other
stars a little bit to go you know what
i'm
okay you know his backlash wasn't that
bad i can sit out now that i feel
uncomfortable you know i just wonder if
some guys are afraid to deal with the
peer pressure as well you know you got
to deal with the peer pressure wait i
want to make money uh wait i don't want
to bring the virus home to you know my
kids who might have asthma or my mom or
my grandma who lives with me which goes
on a lot in the nfl and i think those
are all the things that are uh going to
be interesting to see here over the next
week
and you know what there may be a
disconnect between what players say
publicly about those who choose to opt
out and what they say privately among
themselves or in their text message
chains because there is that that uh
bravado yeah that goes
football definitely yeah and and and you
know what if demarcus lawrence decides
to walk away uh i would suspect that the
cowboys would would take the money that
they were going to pay lawrence this
year and uh issue his number 90 to
davey and clowney and say here you go
you're right
join the team yeah we got a spot for you
so uh we'll see if those dominoes fall
but you're right no star player yet will
it happen six days until the window on
opting out close
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports